il ya trois jours où un homme noir et
tshirt boxe a perdu la vie vendredi soir
la police intervient à la suite d'un
appel pour un homme endormi au volant de
sa voiture qui bloque le service à
l'auto d'un restaurant le policier lui
demande de déplacer sa voiture
c'est ce qu'on voit en ce moment en
deuxième position arrive sur les lieux
lui fait passer un alcootest tout se
passe bien entre les deux policiers
bloquent ce jusqu'à ce que le policier
tente de lui passer les menottes brooks
se défend l'un des policiers dégaine
sont résumées prévient brooks qui
pourrait s'en servir
brooks s'empare du teaser frappé pose y
arrive à s'échapper en s'enfuyant on le
voit se retourner vers le policier qui
le pourchassent et pointé le teaser en
sa direction
c'est à ce moment que le policier fait
feu richard brooks reçoit deux coups de
fusil dans le dos et l'homme décède à
l'hôpital alors bonsoir à tous les deux
je voulais un peu revoir le fil des
événements avec vous d'abord avec vous
monsieur bourgeois sont décrites le
geste comme à ce que les policiers
auraient pu faire autrement dès le début
de l'incident au moment où il le réveil
endormi au volant de sa voiture ce qui
est intéressant c'est que un des
policiers dans le vidéo j'ai regardé un
délit policiers qui décrit vraiment à
coeur indique du sens bête en état
d'ébriété mais malgré ces observations
demandons monsieur le déplacer son
véhicule tout ce fric en tant qu il si
je regarde sophie jugie la misère à
comprendre un peu la logique si tu
conserves comme les widgets en état
d'ébriété lui demander de déplacer son
véhicule
la possibilité que les individus
s'échappe avec son vivre dès lors en
pompe dans un autre scénario donc
l'approché initiale à mon avis à moi
était quand même comme les mercier par
la suite tout sans se dérouler
normalement jusqu'à ce que vous avez
mentionné au moment où est ce que on
essaie de mettre les menottes à détruite
en question et pour vous monsieur
journée est ce qu'on peut se poser la
question pourquoi le menotter c'est ce
qui a mis lui
damas et qui a dégénéré par la suite ça
fait déjà une vingtaine de minutes que
les policiers monsieur et monsieur
brooks et conversait d'une certaine
manière oui tout à fait on peut on peut
se poser la question
qu'ils veuillent le procédé à son
arrestation c'est pas forcément pas une
erreur dans ce sens que la personne
accueillie une infraction assez
clairement et les l'air du temps est
habilité il était au volant de sa
voiture cela étant dit ce qu on peut se
questionner c'est pourquoi demeurant la
personne ce débat véritablement et le
combat se fait de combat se poursuit
pourquoi ne pas le laisser finalement
c'est chacun sait la question moi je me
pose parce que si vous voulez les
policiers on mettra lisez danger pour la
sécurité publique
dire que l'individu en état d'ébriété
une fuite au volant de sa voiture et il
n'a aucune possibilité de reprendre loto
ils ont identifié la personne dont qui
dans tout les éléments en main pour
éventuellement même le retrouver ensuite
une sanction au sénat ou comme
personnellement je me questionne
pourquoi au moment de 2 où l'individu ce
débat n'est pas finalement le laisser
partir mais en même temps pourquoi elle
était celle absolument nécessaire de
l'arrêter laquelle va démontrer mais il
voulait s'en aller à pied chez sa soeur
semble-t-il monsieur bourgeois mais moi
ce que je regarde c'est parce que ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est ce qui a
précédé l'intervention initiale c'est à
dire que l'individu s'est quand même
rendu en état d'ébriété à cet endroit là
au restaurant one [__] et dans ce
contexte les policiers à ce moment là on
était appelée lady vie du d'or et
s'éteint c'est un jugement de la part
des policiers s'ils procèdent à
l'arrestation ou évidemment il décide de
demander s'il veut contacter un hubert
ont amené chez sa soeur ou et cetera
donc il faut il faut comprendre qu'une
un aspect légal cette intervention la
queue que les policiers doivent à ce
moment le juger selon les circonstances
si oui ou non intervention appropriée
comme par exemple lui demandé de
l'accompagner ce que j'ai tour est
l'élément
l'enchère n'accoucha c'est le fait
passer des menottes le laisse budget la
conversation était quand même tout à
fait normal et dans ces circonstances
leur airbus et bleu mandat d'exiger
d'eux le suivait le véhicule de police
est simplement là soir à l'intérieur lui
qu' il ait laissé s'enfuir ou lui tiré
dans l'eau on a le possible il tire dans
le dos rond se positionne a déjà été
congédié monsieur millions alors
l'option ici c'est quoi contre le
laisser s'enfuir ou de tirer dans le dos
pense qu'il n'y a pas une grande
discussion va voir wade et sy s'enfuir
quand même nery pas de mourir parce que
nos communes en france non et qu'est-ce
qui est dans la culture policière
américaine selon vous qu on doit on
parle de surtout depuis la sphère george
forrest bien qu'ils avaient eu d'autres
incidents dans les semaines auparavant
qu'est-ce que dans cette culture
policière selon vous monsieur bourgeois
qui manifestement inacceptables
est-ce que tu est intéressant c'est que
je peux pas m'empêcher de comparer ce
qui se passe ou ou canado quand la
plupart des des agences policières qui
les politiques sont tombés reçoivent une
formation ce qui a trait à la gestion
d'intervention dans des situations un
telle que celle là et il ya un modèle
aspire
ou est ce que le policier temps dans la
mesure du possible de 2 d escalader les
l'intervention pour justement s'assurer
la meilleure la meilleure meilleur
résultat possible
le policier doit tenir compte par
exemple des considérations tactiques
tels que l'éclairage la présence de
renforts dont couvert à proximité est ce
que l'étude est un individu connu dans
le coq homme comme patrick trémeau note
de mentionner l'individu secours et yoyo
il ya à ce moment alors des recours
autre que la force qui ont été
appliquées dans ces circonstances là
pour justement arrêté l'individu
un peu plus tard en métal ça nous amène
à parler de la situation au canada 2
incident aggrave en une semaine monsieur
millions de cas un pic à la grc y aura
une enquête du bureau des enquêtes
indépendantes du québec
il y en a pas la vidéo concernant le
champ tellement non plus que rené lévy
on avait sur lui
la viola semaine dernière du chef adam
ii qui a été frappée comme s'ils étaient
des joueurs de football en fait
qu'est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ça
soulève des questions pour vous vous me
posez la question excusez moi c'est sûr
que je connais pas
on connaît pas grand chose en fait de ce
qui s'est passé nous voir c'est
extrêmement compliqué de juger de dire
ça n'aurait dû se dérouler ceci ou cela
dans le cas de madame vous en faites ce
qui est intéressant de ce qu'on sait en
fait c'est que c'est un appel pour toi
lié à un problème de santé mentale de
quelqu'un qu'il s'inquiétait pour ma
d'amour et qu'il a donc vraiment appeler
le 9 1 1 qui a demandé un policier de
venir et je pense que ça s'est plutôt
alors assez intéressant comme constitue
à sion parce que ça pose la question de
de nous en tant que société en fait
pourquoi est ce que dans notre société
lorsque quelqu'un un problème de santé
mentale c'est souvent la police qui se
retrouve à devoir être des places en
déplacement et sont occupés et je pense
que ça c'est c'est un problème assez
globale de la société canadienne qui a
l'art de l'ensemble est en fait du
système pénal qui est un peu un système
qui prend en charge beaucoup trop les
gens avec des problèmes de santé mentale
que ce soit au niveau des polices la
justice ou les prisons et c'est pas tant
la faute de la police que de la faute
plus globale de la société je pense de
ne pas s'être pourvue d'autres services
d'autres moyens qui serait le moyen
numéro un a appelé quand quelqu'un a un
trouble de santé mentale et qu'on a
besoin d'une intervention il pour vous
monsieur pour dire là dessus ça fera le
mot de la fin fut monsieur je rejoins
parfaitement parce que la situation qui
s'est déroulée malheureusement la
tragédie vendredi dernier dans de 1.0
blanchi avec monsieur livrer le chef
lui-même reconnu dans un autre vu que
qu'il y avait rencontré cet individu
juin le chef de bande avait rencontré
les bidules le vendredi matin et ce vide
j'avais remarqué qu'il y avait ce y
avait tenté de se rendre à l'hôpital la
mère me chie pour des problèmes de santé
mentale qui avait mis aux chefs qui
avait pas dormi depuis au moins deux ou
trois jours et les policiers à ce moment
à ne plus tard dans la même journée sont
appelés vers 4h30 croire à une résidence
parce que les gens veulent que cet
individu loeb quitte les policiers
arrivent sur les lieux l'individu se
précipitent sur les policiers avec avec
un arme blanche
donc encore une fois pour rejoindre le
point c'est qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de de situation alors que les policiers
interviennent et qu'il devrait être
accompagné entre autres de possiblement
d'un terrain d'un intervenant social
pour pouvoir justement gérer une
situation quand on fait face par exemple
à des situations à ce que des individus
ont des problèmes ou des troubles
mentaux
merci beaucoup monsieur bonjour merci
monsieur millions de ça ça provoquera
certainement une réflexion plus
approfondie